russia is now threatening
american assets in response to the first
round of sanctions to the first round of
sanctions
uh let's start there
business insider reporting russia
threatens to target sensitive u.s assets
as part of a strong and painful response
to u.s sanctions its foreign minister
foreign affairs ministry said the
sanctions were attempt to change
russia's course
there should be no doubt that sanctions
will receive a strong response
russia's foreign affairs ministry said
the country would target sensitive
american assets in retaliation the
ministry said this is part
of america's the sanctions are part of
america's ongoing attempts to change
russia's course
russia has proved that despite all the
sanctions cost it is able to minimize
the damage and even more so sanctions
pressure is not able to affect our
determination to firmly defend our
interests it added there should be no
doubt that sanctions will receive a
strong response not necessarily
symmetrical but finely tuned and painful
to the american side the united states
on the other hand plans to continue
escalating the sanctions i don't even
pretend to know where this will end
but it is very clear
that all along you know we had we had
reports which said
here's what we know
here's what could happen
and then here's a less bad scenario
just about every element of this so far
has been closer to the worst case
scenario now obviously there were people
talking about nuclear war
uh as a worst case scenario i don't
believe that will happen i don't believe
we're going in that direction uh i think
that that that's that's quite literally
it would be a suicide decision uh by
putin and russia but from from the sort
of more reasonable could this be trying
to take a little bit of territory could
this escalate into bombing kiev it's all
going in the worst direction
uh and economically it's also already
doing significant significant damage
understand also by the way that
russia has changed its tune on the
sanctions pretty quickly i mean two days
ago russia was saying we don't care
about sanctions they're not really going
to do anything
now russia is saying
the sanctions are
painful and we are going to retaliate
specifically for the sanctions so it
should not be lost on us that russia has
changed its opinion of the sanctions as
stated so that's the latest that we know
at this point within two hours things
may have changed we will of course be
live later with the latest
and you can find me on twitter at d
pacman and let me know your latest
thoughts on what's taking place
i want to introduce you to emmy the
world's first instant ramen that is low
carb high protein and 100
plant based each serving of imi is
packed with 21 grams of protein
19 grams of fiber has only five net
carbs works for keto diets and 35
percent less sodium than traditional
ramen brands i've been making it at home
just like any instant ramen it's ready
in just a few minutes you can use the
microwave you can use the stovetop you
really can't beat the convenience but
with imme you can feel good about the
ramen you're eating because of all the
fiber the lower sodium and it is
plant-based which i love even though i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but the best
part is it's so well packaged it comes
in flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp
black garlic chicken the taste and the
quality of the ingredients really sets
it apart from any other instant ramen
i've had and emmy is giving my audience
five dollars off a variety pack when you
go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is down below